وفي ابرز ردود الفعل الاقليميه على عوده
العلاقات السعوديه الايرانيه رحبت وزاره
الخارجيه العراقيه بالاتفاق معتبره اياه
ايذانا ببدء صفحه جديده من العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين البلدين من جهه اقاله
وزاره الخارجيه اللبنانيه ان اتفاق
السعوديه وايران سيترك اثره الايجابي على
مجمل العلاقات الاقليميه في حين اعرب
الامين العام لحزب الله اللبناني حسن نصر
الله عن سعادته باستئناف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين الرياض وطهران
وقال نصر الله في كلمه له ان لديه الثقه
ان ذلك سيكون لمصلحه شعوب المنطقه معتبرا
ان الاتفاق السعوديه الايراني يمكن ان
يفتح الافاق في كل المنطقه ومن ضمنها
لبنان بينما قال الناطق باسم حركه انصار
الله الحوثيين محمد عبد السلام ان المنطقه
بحاجه لعوده العلاقات الطبيعيه بين دولا
هذا وقالته ازاله خارجيه المصريه انها
تابعت باهتمام الاتفاق الذي تم الاعلان
عنه باستئناف العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين
السعوديه وايران وعربت الخارجيه المصريه
في بيان عن تطلعاتها باي سوى الاتفاق في
تخفيف حده التوتر في المنطقه وزاره
الخارجيه الاردنيه كذلك اعربت عن امرها ان
الاتفاق السعودي الايراني في تعزيز الامن
في المنطقه بما يحفظ سياده الدول في حين
اعتبرت الخارجيه التركيه ان استئناف
العلاقات بين ايران والسعوديه خطوه هامه
ستسهم في امن المنطقه واستقرارها
وفي اول رد فعل رسميا اسرائيلي على
استئناف العلاقات السعوديه الايرانيه
اعتبر مرسول اسرائيلي في حاطه رسميه ان
الاتفاق بين الطرفين سيؤثر على امكانيه
التطوير العلاقات بين الرياضه اللبيب لكن
المسؤول الايطاليه اضافنا في احاطته ان
قوه الغرب في موقفهم من ايران ستقلل من
اهميه تطبيع العلاقات بين الرياض وطهران
بحسب تعبيره